all right so now we're moving into
rational functions these as you recall
other ones that are going to end up at
logs now you've got your reference sheet
there but in case you don't have it you
know on hand I want you to remember what
we're searching for is something of the
form F dash on F if you have something
like this and you're integrating it then
you will get log of the absolute value
of that particular function of course
plus a constant if you have an
indefinite integral so therefore I have
a look at this particular question here
and I think well I've got a bottom
function there of 5 minus 2x what I want
the numerator therefore to look like is
negative 2 and it's not negative 2 at
the moment so before I do any calculus
I'm gonna reshape this question so that
it looks neater for me to work with so
that looks like this f dash on F
situation so for starters I'm at 3 on
the numerator right now it's not helping
me at all so I'm going to get rid of it
straight away when I say get rid off I
mean factorize it outside of the
integral so that gives me a 3 at the
front I'm still integrating from 1 to 2
and then there's a 1 on the numerator ok
so the 3 is out of the way and now as I
pointed out what I want is that negative
2 on the numerator in here now I can't
just put a negative 2 there because
convenient to me if I'm multiplying this
by negative 2 then to compensate I need
to divide by a negative 2 as well
because that way everything stays
preserve just like you know if I were
saying to you okay if I want to simplify
a fraction like this then I would divide
the top and then I would also divide the
bottom right so here I'm going to I'll
do it in another color so you can see it
I'm going to multiply the top by
negative 2 which means that I'm also
going to divide by negative 2 like so
everything is still balanced just like
doing the top and the bottom in a
fraction so this is 3 at the front I'm
still integrating from 1 to 2 and then
on the denominator I have 5
- 2x let's move that negative to over
because slightly bothering me that it's
not in the middle okay so hopefully you
can see there the colors make it clear
what I'm doing is that negative - in
that negative to balance out but they're
better for me from an integration
standpoint because now inside the
integral
I've got F dash on F let's tidy up that
constant coefficient at the front the
trait is negative 3 over 2 big square
brackets because now I'm actually doing
the integration it's log of the absolute
value of 5 - 2 X
there we go from 1 to 2 I'm going to now
do the evaluation so there's the
negative 3 over 2 still hanging out the
front actually let's leave that as a
square bracket because I'm gonna have a
few brackets on the inside log of the
absolute value of 5 minus 2 lots of 2 is
4 so that's 5 take away 4 I'm going to
subtract the lower bound so this is now
log of the absolute value of 5 take away
- lots of 1 is 2 there we go
let's see what can I do here well this
is negative 3 on 2 at the front and then
log of 5 minus 4 is the log of 1 + log
of 5 minus 2 is log of 3 now remember
this natural log of 1 in fact the log of
any base of 1 is that power that if you
race that power you'll get 1 that power
can only be 0 of course if you had
trouble remembering it the calculator
will help you out I'm gonna get 0
takeaway log 3 which can't be simplified
at this point
double negative happening so it looks to
me like I get 3 log 3 on 2 and the
question I believe asked for 4
significant figures so I'm gonna reach
back for my calculator over here I
haven't actually entered this value yet
so let's let's do it together what have
I got here so this is gonna be three
functions natural log 3 and the whole
thing is divided by 2 so I've got a
value here just like I mentioned before
I'm gonna write the entire calculator
display one point six four seven nine
one eight
three three etc and now I'm going to do
my approximation so four significant
figures I've already got the unit then
I'm gonna go tenths hundredths
thousandths so that's six four eight two
four significant figures done okay that
was the first of the rational functions
let's have a look at this next one
now it's an area and they've provided
the graph to us how generous and
gracious of them they say find the area
of the region in the first quadrant so
you can see here the corner axes here
tell us that this is the fourth quadrant
up in the top right bounded by this
curve here so let's have a look how
we're gonna write this so I think the
best way is to say let's call this guy
the red function which one is that well
it's gonna be this curvy one over yeah
hopefully when you look at this sir at
this algebra here you recognize that
this is going to be a hyperbola and then
my contrast you have this guy Y goes
choose let's choose another color here
mmm great y equals two over here this is
the horizontal line that goes right over
the top here right so let me just go all
the way across to like so finally they
then provide us with some X boundaries
so x equals one x equals two these
corresponds to their vertical lines that
you can see and that's how we end up
with this blue region that's shaded so
how do we find this region well this is
an area between two curves we could
construct excuse me a rectangle around
this and then look at the area under the
curve but we actually already have a
direct way to work out areas between
curves we would say that the area is the
integral from the bottom to the top
which in this case has just been
provided to us straight out and what we
want is the top take away the bottom now
you just have to look carefully and work
out which one is which in this case the
top function is the green one and the
bottom one is the red one now what
happens if you get this incorrect what
will happen is if you do them the other
way around you're going to get the same
magnitude of of value for the definite
integral but it'll be negative and
because a lot of people realize at that
point
I have an area I better make it positive
some people would just take that in mind
that value let's say it was like a
negative 3 and they'll say on the next
line oh oh it's an area and they'll just
say 3 units squared ok now I just want
to make a big song idea to say this is
not a good idea in fact what's this
betrays is you didn't understand what
you were doing you just notice that
something went wrong and you'll better
fix it ok it's a real it's a real fudge
is the way we mathematicians would call
it what you want to do here is instead
get the integral right in the correct
order rather than just getting it wrong
and then say uh-oh I'm not meant to have
that because that betrays our lack of
understanding so it's important that I
identify which functions which which
ones top which ones bottom I've done
that so like we said the top one's the
straight line it just has a function of
two there it is the top function and
then I subtract the bottom function
which in this case is 2 minus 2 over X
or with respect to X so I hope you can
see that simplifies into that or
substitutes I should say in that
substitutes into there as we've seen
before it is important to do any
simplification you can before actually
integrated because integrating is a lot
of work and so the less I can do of it
and the more I can simplify in other
ways the better so before I do my
integration I noticed that there's going
to be two takeaway - so that's cancels
then I've got a negative and a negative
here so these cancel as well leaving me
with just this last term on the end here
that 2 over X how convenient so this is
my function and by now hopefully we're
familiar enough that this is just going
to give us as a primitive log rather to
log the absolute value of X there's our
primitive function substituting 1 & 2
and pretty rapidly you're going to get
let's do this oh yeah well it doesn't
matter too much let's do the 2 there and
then the 1 fair this is just like before
log of 1 is 0 so all you get is 2 log 2
I'll look back at the question did they
ask us to approximate in any way and the
answer is no they did and so therefore
I'm going to leave it exact as log of so
thing but I have said it's an area so
I'm going to say therefore the area is I
have my value and now I put on my units
which in this case is square units don t